this is sal here and i'm here with ben
eater who i consider to be an expert at
many things what are we going to talk
about today enthusiast
any event let's talk about uh
semiconductors and semiconductors this
is you know
the computing revolution and electronics
the phones in our pockets that they all
are made of chips that have
semiconductors in them right right and
they're made from silicon silicon and so
that's why we have this this periodic
table here we see silicon right over
here with an atomic number of 14 which
means it has 14 protons and a neutral
silicon would also have 14 electrons
right
right but what we care about is the
electrons that are in the outermost
shell the valence the valence electrons
right so silicon and you know for any
viewers who are unfamiliar we have a
whole series of videos on valence
electrons encourage them to watch this
if if what ben and i are talking about
right now seems a little confusing but
silicon has a neutral silicon atom will
have 14 electrons but the four and the
outermost shell are the ones that are
likely to react and so when chemists
depict silicon or when they think about
how it might react they think primarily
about these four electrons but just
because we drew these four these are
four valence electrons there's another
10 for a neutron a neutral silicon atom
that would be sitting closer to the
nucleus right but those don't react with
with other atoms as much so we don't we
don't really think about those
um
but so in in a semiconductor you've got
basically a whole crystal
of silicon atoms so let's let's see if
we can imagine that yeah so let's let's
so we have a crystal here so if each of
these circles are a silicon atom and if
we imagine and we're only going to think
about the valence electrons so the one
this silicon atom it has four valence
electrons so it could be one
two
three
and four valence electrons and so it
could be bonded to a neighboring silicon
let me do this in a different color so
we can keep track of its valence
electrons
to a neighboring silicon whose valence
electrons are one
two
three
and four and when we see what happened
here is that they they formed a a
covalent bond which allows both of these
silicons to share both of these
electrons yeah so you've sort of drawn
them in different colors but really both
of those
both of those feel like they kind of own
the both of them right
and in chemistry and once again you know
we cover this a lot in the in the
chemistry section of khan academy is
you atoms get stable when they when they
can pretend or they feel like they have
eight valence electrons right and so if
a silicon does this with four other
silicons it can pretend like it has
eight valence electrons like this one
right over here it kind of feels like it
partially owns two four six eight
electrons even though it only
contributed four the other four come
from the neighboring silicon yeah and
all of the silicon atoms in this in this
crystal structure i feel that way so
this is a very stable
right right stable right and once again
what we're seeing is just a slice a
two-dimensional slice this thing would
be three-dimensional yeah it's a
two-dimensional depiction really because
the bonds are you know three-dimensional
right but yeah it's a representation
right so what we're interested in is is
we're talking about computers and and
electronics and and so we want to talk
about current flow yep um and so i guess
the question is is can current flow
through this is this a conductor well
the way i mean what we've just talked
about it looks like everything would be
stable here there doesn't seem a lot of
a strong incentive for you know even if
you were to put a current across this
and let's do that even if you were to
put a current
so if i were to put a current across
this so there's a battery right over
here
so this is a battery
right over here
and this is the negative side the
negative terminal this is the positive
terminal and we typically talk about
current going from positive to negative
but we know that it's actually the
electrons are flowing this is a
yeah it's a little confusing
unfortunately i guess benjamin franklin
had a 50 percent chance of getting this
right and he got it wrong he got it
wrong well he did many other good things
and yeah we'll excuse him
we'll give him a pass but the electrons
the electrons want to you know if you
have a complete circuit if the electrons
can go all the way around they would go
to the positive terminal right but all
of these electrons in this silicon
lattice it looks like they're pretty
happy there's no reason for them to move
good conductors you know when we think
about the transition metals things like
copper they have a sea of electrons lots
of free electrons
and these are these metallic bonds in
fact this you know with this this wire
that we have right over here if it was
made out of say copper it would have
just a lot of free electrons right the
sea of electrons that could that could
flow but here looks like the electrons
are pretty happy where they are they
don't they don't really have a a lot of
incentive to move around right so how is
this useful when we're building
something it doesn't seem to computer or
something yes yeah so it by itself it's
not um so what we do is we we um we add
some impurities to the silicon um and we
call this process doping i see we're
just adding some impurity to the silicon
that that um
lets us conduct electricity and let us
do some interesting things can they be
like any impurity no so they're actually
very specific impurities and so one one
common impurity is phosphorus i see so
let's look at the periodic table i
always like to anytime i hear the name
of an element i need to refer to the
periodic table
to get my bearings all right so
phosphorus look it's right next to
silicon on the periodic table it is it
has an atomic number of 15. and so it's
it's a neutral phosphorus would have 15
protons in its nucleus and 15 electrons
but if we think about its valence
electrons it would have one more valence
electrons right it has five
it would have five
valence electrons yeah and that fifth
valence electron is like super important
okay so let's let's think about what's
going on here so if i were to so listen
if i were to replace this silicon with a
let me pick a good color to do this with
blue if i were to if i were to replace
this silicon with a phosphorus
it would have it could have one
two
three
four but then it has a fifth valence
electron that wouldn't be able to form a
covalent bond right so it's just kind of
sitting there sort of sitting there
right and let me do that again over
maybe maybe this this one already here
is a phosphorus and so
this is one
two
three
four and then it has a fifth valence
electron it has these extra electrons
yes you have extra electrons and they're
they're free to move around they're not
stuck in these covalent bonds right
those covalent bonds is kind of a stable
configuration you have you know the
eight valence electrons but here you had
these extra ones and so yeah they're
more
liberated i guess right right and and
and so if we go to we have this battery
hooked up here you have this positive
terminal yeah down here you have this
positive terminal and electrons are
going to be attracted to that yeah so
this one this one right over here
eventually you know it might be able to
be you know it could be attracted to
that one that one could move there that
one could move and eventually get to the
wire yeah right like this guy could
replace that guy could replace that guy
and eventually the electrons could start
could start flowing yeah could start
with that or i mean
the way we're looking at this is a width
of two atoms it could it could kind of
make that leap
right oh it could even make the leap it
could just go straight to yeah yeah but
yeah
so so this stuff could start could start
flowing and if this if this extra if
this extra phosphorus electron were to
move start moving to the right then this
is going to be then this phosphorus is
going to have a positive charge and so
maybe it grabs an electron from here and
then that grabs an electron from the
wire and so you start to have current
flowing yeah yeah we got current flowing
fascinating interesting so there's
that's one way okay of doping silicon to
get current to flow through it there's
another way all right and that is with
something like boron all right let's get
another lattice here
all right so let me get go back to the
periodic table you just said boron i did
so boron has an atomic number let me let
me go back to let me pick up good let me
do purple for boron boron color yeah
good boron color so boron has an atomic
number of five but once again if you
care about its valence electrons it has
three electrons in its outer most
shell
so borons valence might look like that
depending on the convention you use so
let's dope this this silicon lattice
with a little bit of boron let's do it
so the ones that are not labeled we'll
just assume are silicon but i'll throw a
couple of borons in here so this is a
boron the boron would have so it's one
two
three valence electrons so let me get
rid of this one because that one would
have only been there if this was silicon
right so let me get let me change the
color actually let me
so let me actually get rid of this one
oh oops that's not the right color
this right over here so
because boron only has three valence
electrons it's not able to form this
fourth covalent bond here and let me do
a couple more borons like that so maybe
this is
a boron right over here and it has
one
two
three valence electrons and so this
wasn't able to form this fourth covalent
bond and so it almost feels like there's
a hole here yeah and that's actually
exactly what it's called is a whole what
it called i should go into naming things
very creative so these so yeah so these
are called holes those are called holes
um there are places where an electron
would want to be in a normal silicon
crystal but but there isn't one there
because we've introduced this boron
impurity i see i think i see where this
is going because you know just as having
these extra valence electrons introduced
kind of a imbalance and allowed
electrons to flow made it a little bit
less stable yep this is also kind of an
imbalance a little bit less stable yeah
a little less stable so let's hook a
battery up to it let's see what happens
yeah let's put a battery on this
so
let's put a battery on this
and we get
this is the positive this is the
negative so let's see if this is this is
the positive so electrons want to go
here electrons are going to be attracted
to the positive terminal yeah
okay but but in this case we maybe don't
have a lot of free electrons we actually
have more holes than we have electrons
we have more holes in electrons so what
could happen is is the electrons that
are coming from the negative terminal
they could they could you know they
could make their way or you know kind of
a chain uh uh kind of electron start
forming but eventually these electrons
can this electron
can fill
this
yeah it's a nearby hole a nearby hole
and then maybe you know the the whole
kind of will will transition to the you
know one way to think about it is if if
this electron here fills this hole then
you have a hole here
yeah just like the electrons could kind
of wander around when we had the
phosphorus over on the left right the
holes are kind of free to wander around
a bit right
those kind of give a place where the
electrons can jump to exactly yeah so
electrons coming out of that negative
terminal the battery are going to find a
nearby hole
and when they do that then the boron you
know where where that hole is filled is
going to be a little bit more positively
charged so another electron or a little
more negative a little more negative
right right negatively charged yeah so
then a hole is going to want to free up
so that electron is going to is going to
move right i see so what will eventually
happen i mean just what we depicted this
electron could go there then it would be
a hole here and then you know maybe that
electron could eventually get to the
wire over here and then the electrons
will move to the right the electrons
will move to the right across the wire
and form a current right while the holes
kind of move the holes will move to the
left to the left yeah and you can almost
view the holes as kind of a positive
thing even though it's a non-thing yeah
we actually yeah we do like to think of
the holes as moving um even though yeah
it is kind of a it's a gas sensor it's
an absence of something moving but but
yeah we think of the holes as moving and
so in both of these cases one case we
have electrons moving in one case we
have holes moving right and we have
there's a term for this they're called
charge carriers charge carriers
so either the electrons or or the the
holes are both considered charge
carriers because they allow a charge to
be carried through this material right
they both create kind of an imbalance
with the phosphorus creates an extra
electrons this creates holes it can be
filled by other electrons and then the
holes can kind of keep moving yeah and
so in the case on the left we call this
well n type material n-type material
that makes sense i'm guessing n for
negative
carrier right right because the the
electrons are negative and then
the boron doped thing on the right we
call p-type p-type makes sense and these
are the the two types of of silicon
that we use in semiconductors
fascinating i think i can already see
where this could go